pete davidson celebrates his birthday
with kim kardashian amid rumors the two
are dating i don't know where these
rumors come from
and guys
they're wearing matching pjs
yes
on wednesday rapper flavor flav shared
these snaps from the 28 year old
comedian's birthday bash including this
pick with pete and this one of pete with
kim and kim's mom kris jenner it was the
cutest thing and if you look closely the
group appears to be wearing the latest
holiday pajamas from the reality star's
shapewear and clothing line skins and
pete well he's wearing the top from
kim's plaid sleep set complete with a
pink t-shirt and shorts
i love that flavor flav captioned the
post in part quote celebrating my
adopted son pete davidson's birthday
with the legends kim kardashian and kris
jenner it's really lit and fun and crazy
the latest kim and pete hang come
shortly after the saturday night live
star opened up about his dating deal
breaker during an appearance on iheart
media's river cafe table 4 podcast with
host and celebrity chef ruth rogers if
you went to a restaurant and and your
date was rude to the waiter
or was you know then that would be over
wouldn't it would you ever
immediately would uh
in my head i'd be like okay never this
is it is that pete who has previously
been linked to stars like ariana grande
and kaia gerber also shared another
dating don't i don't like the excuse me
it's like wait for the guy to walk by
and then just lightly i think that also
people who have worked in a restaurant
it teaches you something doesn't it the
best lessons i've learned have been from
working in that restaurant like learning
how to work with people learning how to
act around certain people that don't
like you
earlier this month the source told et
that pete a staten island native had
dinner with kim in his hometown at
italian restaurant campania they were
spotted out together again at new york
hot spot zero bond and at the time an
eyewitness told e.t that kim seemed like
she was having fun and very happy we'll
just have to wait and see
as for any budding romance between the
two a source previously told et that the
actor and the kkw beauty founder are
taking things slow quote kim and pete
are casually dating and seeing where
things go pete is really into kim and
excited about her kim likes pete as well
but isn't rushing into anything serious
on monday night etie caught up with
pete's snl co-star alex moffatt when
asked about rumors that his buddy may be
dating kim he played coy
i don't really stay up to date with what
my good friend pete's up to i just hope
he's vaccinated as long as he's having
fun and he's happy that's all i care
about he's a love
speaking of fun that's exactly what a
separate source told et earlier this
month explaining that the funny guy and
reality star are trying to play it off
like they're just friends but it's a
little more than that right now quote
they're having a lot of fun together
pete makes kim laugh and makes her feel
special pete is obviously thrilled and
has a major crush on kim
[Music]
you